hey folks down here with a gamespot news
update did you know that titanfall got
itself an update with new game modes and
sweet balance tweaks titan falls patch
went live this morning and the most
significant change comes in the form of
new game modes the first of which is
live now the second on its way the mode
introduced today is called marked for
death which resembles counterstrikes VIP
mode a player on each team is designated
as a target so you must devote your time
to killing the enemies target and
protecting your own or if you are the
target running like hell the next game
mode will be called wingman last Titan
standing which is a 2v2 Titan showdown
another feature implemented today was
tightened customization besides being
able to choose from new Titan voices
caution you are out la chocha one you
can unlock insignias to decorate your
titans you burn cards are tight and
specific for instance extended electric
smoke time or do a particle walls these
burn cards last until you dies at IDing
so you won't get to waste him if you die
running around as a pilot auto titans
got an AI upgrade as well they are now
able to use all their abilities such as
deploying electronic smoke when the
enemy player jumps on them there are a
variety of changes in bug fixes as well
as weapon balancing or in most cases
weapon nerfing the r101 shotgun and big
punch among others we're considered
overpowered and so nerfed while some
under use guns such as the hemlock or 97
and g2 got a small boost there are bunch
more little new tweaks and features out
of titanfall to get out there and check
it out for our upcoming news on
titanfall make sure to stay tuned
gamespot com
you